[Music]
in pointless rule news in all rules
points yes like the law for not
murdering you know don't rape in public
rape in private please be decent good
points admitted by Cheetos or Doritos
Cheetos all the way to Reno aiming hot
cheetos he did you can't make it your
ceiling Doritos on Reno's ranch you
can't picture said Cheetos bow I don't
want cheese Cheetos Doritos in Dorito
yeah but they're like regular original
Doritos because both of them are really
bad how dare you you [ __ ] that's like
saying you want the yellow starburst or
the orange starburst they both [ __ ]
sauce orange white the white gummy bear
or the green gummybear with the hairy
both green is Apple oh yeah it's like
one flavor dumb-dumb or another flavor
dumb-dumb like who the [ __ ] cares are
both tragic why do they have that for
always likes weight like the rupee yeah
yeah [ __ ] weirdos I know if you like
the green or the purple your your weirdo
alway flavors lock them up lock lock
moment [ __ ] Judas at a Pennsylvania
school are being forced to smile while
walking in the hallways that's like
Singapore man I like Singapore you have
to smile
yeah I feel I feel like that I feel like
they do cuz like they all are like fake
smiles like the dog conditioning where
they're not confident you just lift the
tail up constantly and it helps them be
confident that's how you give y'all
confidence well actually it even works
it works in humans so you did it there's
how your internal psychology affects
your physical expression but there's
also it works in the reverse so as if
you're a sad ass [ __ ]
if you physically smile more it will
make you more positive on music
someone's forcing me to do anything
though I'm immediately pissed like I'll
smile are you like that smile yes it's
not for you but if you do it long enough
you actually believe it
you actually believe it if you do it
long you like that [ __ ] geo that's a
real smog oh that's creepy me to do it
it's like all like but if you do it long
enough you'll believe it but if someone
is like hey here's a tip if you do this
more blood I'm Michael I should try that
out I'll do it then it works and that's
cool but someone's like you got to do
this I'm like that's a bit cool saying
so they're saying that if you are
walking down the hallways and if you
don't smile you get called to the office
would you like my mom just died
[ __ ]
then they're gonna make you see a
guidance counselor and you have to talk
about your problems then or else you get
to love to do that see you then I'm just
like this the whole time
amantha syrians are dreams oh no
Pennsylvania did the [ __ ] witch hunt
[ __ ] right or know that Salem Salem
close enough they got the pilgrims and
what is it the [ __ ] Quaker Oats guys
the Amish is man you can see got that
means you know cinco's is the whiskey I
thought that the Quakers the guy in the
home manufacture old mill you know the
olds are made by the Quakers the Quaker
thinking smell real no it's taken the
oatmeal
all right the happy pirates like
they're like the pipes before they
actually saw some [ __ ] anatomy before
they went through a lot of problems
that's what Pirates used to look like so
this whole rule here it's so stupid to
everyone involved except for the
principal who enacted this rule here
because parents and teachers and
students are saying like we have a real
bullying problem at this school but
that's being ignored and what a waste of
time now we're being forced to smile so
it's like hey I know you guys again
[ __ ] up by the bullies but smile and
now when you have to tell your problems
like okay what's your problems that I'm
being forced to smile I would just love
to talk to a guidance counselor that'd
be nice you never know no but every time
I talk to a guidance counselors because
they were blaming me for punching people
though that's different blaming you for
punching people you actually punch
people no but God would be bullied oh oh
but did you or did you not punch people
that's irrelevant because I listened to
the story something I did but listen if
they're hurting my feelings
punch ow I'm saying that no they hurt my
feelings and so oh God they emotionally
abused you so you physically abuse them
yes I liked hers better they catch my
face they punch you my feelings they're
making me feel bad and ask them to stop
so I punched their physical feelings
that's [ __ ] hilarious anything on
this high school it's in the northern
Lebanon School District it's northern
Lebanon High School and so yeah a lot of
these parents are just complaining
saying like her daughter has been
bullied at that school and they
complained about it and even
administrative people at that school
also filed complaints but then the
higher-ups like the principal is not
doing anything
about it it's like what's the point of
having such a dumb rule when you can't
even solve actual problems did the
article say how she got bullied it was
like typical bullying stuff like girls
calling your names or like women shoving
her in the hallway one way I could see
it helping it's even if you are bullied
just smile I mean you think that's the
solution it's not the solution but I'm
saying like let's say you're getting
bullied anyways right choose kindness
yeah so if you're getting if you're if
you're getting bullied anyway you might
as well sit back and enjoy it yeah turn
the other cheek
don't be handicapped by it you know I
mean like for example like some people
that get their bike stolen right enjoy
oh [ __ ]
just there's my transportation to go to
school this is like a repetitive thing
every single you know be cool though if
you explained it you just packaged it
wrong it's a woman so reason why it
sucks but then what if she said it this
way she was like she was like you know
what there's always gonna be bullies in
this world but you could control how you
feel that's what I'm saying you could be
like you could smile in the faces of
your enemy instead of saying that this
is her go - same statement or question
is what can you do to be less of the
problem and more of the solution that's
what she's telling kids are being
bullied that's like telling a hungry
person to think about a sandwich yeah
United mean like I'm still hungry [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] is that do you know
we don't make a sandwich yeah I hear so
many things like this and we personally
experienced [ __ ] so much stupidity
coming from the higher-ups yeah in
schools and I'm like how the [ __ ] do
these people get these positions cuz if
you're like a 13 year old and you
[ __ ] outsmart them and you can see
the hypocrisy and the stupidity it's
like how the how the [ __ ] does this
happen and are the people that choose
these administrative jobs and all that
are they all [ __ ] morons yeah you
know it's hard to it's like we we always
have advice for like youth when it comes
to being bully but at the same time I I
can remember being like 15 and 16 and
it's not you don't have that adult
perspective so it's so [ __ ] hard to
do these things that we have solutions
for you know like I'd be able to do it
if I could take my mind now and
come a 15 16 year old of course I be
able to handle because I'm a lot smarter
raging hormones to that also affect the
way and you also have to have these
experiences first to have this mindset
that you have now a part about being a
team dude you've evolved through that
and it's exceed at it if you were a
loser now you'd probably wouldn't even
know what to tell yourself at fifteen
yeah loser
yeah teenager not [ __ ] Phil you I
don't know what it's like man that's
true because if you if your girl right
like and then you never went through
sexual harassment appeasing or whatever
you become a mother
you have a daughter exactly and then you
hear your daughters stories and you go
oh my god really that's scary and then
you get you [ __ ] crying be scared
together instead of being a strong
mother that's like alright I've been
through this [ __ ] this is what
you're gonna do yeah
right yeah cuz I know people like that
[ __ ] but they don't necessarily have to
go through radio and we make it just
educate themselves and help the
daughters that have just being so like
it yeah but if people haven't gone
through it it's scary so it would be
like then making but then forcing them
to smile that's the thing it's like if
you went through an experience and then
you got better from it and then you
learned that this is how to solve it is
by like smiling or whatever then that's
different than being told you have to
smile right more execution well you are
Saints not inspiring she's just like
she's like come demanding yeah she's
like you just need a stuff or something
to smile forcing me to smile actually
makes me more upset that's what I'm
saying it makes me want to rebel against
it and like I've been into like certain
situations where like I clearly don't
want to be at this event right and I had
to force myself to smile and it drains
the life out of mm-hmm and literally
like I'll see like my manager he'll be
next to me and he'll see me he's like do
you top that oh really like he must had
a great time and as we leave the door I
go yeah and he was like what the [ __ ]
you like that you're having a good time
was it yeah I just had to do what I had
to do what I left that's how I am - how
come my natural stage it's not a good
social skill to have instead of having a
[ __ ] face in that environment and
negative what do you think though is
that when it's something is forced upon
you is draining it's forced upon you for
sure it's draining right like no one
wants to be forced to do anything eating
the food you don't like whatever this to
the music you like a hundred percent but
what is being forced upon you is a
positive outlook on what is the worst
thing that could be happening to
so I feel like it's a exercise that can
be used to actually help your brain see
things the other way explain for example
so for example uh when I was in boot
camp
if you ever showed your teeth you're
getting popped in the face and what they
mean by showing your teeth is you know
when you run three miles or whatever
you're breathing like this so the minute
you show your teeth you're getting
popped in the face no matter what they
call holding your bearings and having
composure so you could run something
like the craziest sprint you can go
through a shooting exercise whatever
your face must look like this right and
that's forced upon you or you getting
punched in the face but I want to really
really liked about that exercise is it
teaches you no matter how crazy your
heartbeat is how much you're [ __ ]
sweating ultimately your calmness
depends on you if you don't let
overwhelm you if you let the insides
overwhelm you and you look like like
this then you you end up being
overwhelmed by your emotion so what I
like about this is no matter how much
[ __ ] going through in here it's
still up to you if you want to put this
on and if you want to see it as being
forced then yeah you are being forced
but if someone is telling you this rule
and you can embrace it and put it on I
think you're that much stronger I think
the the job here is that they're not
explaining it like how you're saying it
a leader being able to persuade so if
the lis if the leader can execute like
she probably has great intentions right
anymore the students but all if she's
just saying you got a [ __ ] smile now
and that's it and like what can you do
because it's not the military it's
regular civilian life right she needs to
explain her motive and why and if she
sucks at doing that then it's gonna have
backlash because no one's gonna know why
we're smiling yeah it's like the parrot
touching you for no [ __ ] reason right
it's like it there's no sense and it
takes longer to learn and there's gonna
be resentment between teachers and
students if she was an inspiring
motivational told you you know what no
matter what you know like laughs in the
face of your enemy and that's just gonna
be the best thing you can ever do
throughout life then then you get it
right and you're like
yeah I could control how I feel yeah I
can't control what they do but I can
control how for you yeah so basically I
like it but I think it's poor execution
that's such an interesting thing in the
military that's so dope
you guys made me see what the point of
yeah I changed my perspective yeah I
don't do that now no I'm tired as he was
doing kicks in ready I saw this will
show the [ __ ] out of his team punch me
in the face
[Music]